how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
at the MCU and today we're going to be
talking about Black Widow now
unfortunately you've probably heard that
because of the coronavirus Cove in
nineteen black widows release date has
been pushed back and as of right now
there is no word on any new release date
being set or if they're going to release
it on Disney Plus however today we do
have a plot leaked that does supposedly
reveal the two post-credit scenes for
the Black Widow movie and one of them is
a major set up and a huge reveal for the
future of the MCU we know that Black
Widow is kind of an origin story it
takes place between the events of
Captain America Civil War and of course
Avengers infinity war but it will also
show us
black widows past as well but of course
we knew that Marvel Studios wouldn't
have Black Widow which of course is the
first movie of phase 4 not give us
anything about the future of Marvel so
it makes perfect sense that the
post-credits scene would set up the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so we're gonna break down these leaks
and these post-credit scenes and talk
about what it means for the bloc would a
movie and what it means for the future
of Marvel if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 also if you're
trying to avoid any and all types of
spoilers for Black Widow here is your
official spoiler warning if these leaks
end up being true so today's leak comes
from 4chan which is where the Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame leaks
came from that ended up being accurate
and this new leak that we got actually
ties into some leaks that we've gotten
from the past and proves them to be true
now these previous leaks told us that of
course the villainous taskmaster and
taskmaster is Mason Mason is Natasha's
former lover and a former SHIELD agent
moreover Nats sister from her Black
Widow days Yelena will end up saving
nutz life and killing taskmaster at the
end of the film just as he's about to
get the drop on Natasha and the leaked
States
taskmaster always seems to know where
they will be the film makes you think
that all of her allies could be him he
is able to perfectly mirror all of the
combat styles has a memorable fight with
Red Guardian a dirty bar fight version
of cap first cap an in-game he has a
tank slash mobile command center that
drives itself think Idris Elba's
motorcycle in Hobson
ha this is gonna steal the show in the
same way the arc of the film is very
much this wild world calling Natasha
back to it and her trying to get her
family out of it Mason is revealed to be
taskmaster and kills red Guardian in
front of Natasha and Yelena during a
cinematic fight between all of them and
Melina the remaining black widows turn
on iron maiden and she ends up locked in
the red room torture chamber to get her
justice
Yelena kills taskmaster by shooting him
through his broken mask as he is about
to kill Natasha and this leads us to the
new leak from somebody who claims to
have seen the movie now the film was
supposed to come out in basically a
month it's pretty much done maybe a few
edits here and there but the movie is
complete so there are people who have
definitely seen the movie this is the
same thing that happened in infinity war
and in game the movies were shown to
some people and they ended up posting
what they saw online and this is what
this person saw they say that it's
Marvel Studios his version of Mission
Impossible / John wick saw Black Widow
today and was pleasantly surprised
it's basically a Mission Impossible
sequel with Black Widow replacing Tom
Cruise's Ethan Hunt and it works better
than you'd expect same plot beaks
excommunicated hunted by the government
get this thing so life can go back to
normal
oh no there's a grander conspiracy save
the world give the thing to your sister
deal with the consequences peace out
now we know based off of previous plot
leaks that this so-called thing that
he's talking about in this leak is a
flash drive and apparently on this flash
drive is a program that can erase your
name from any and all databases on earth
basically you get completely off the
grid and your name is cleared so
obviously it would make sense that Black
Widow is searching for this after the
events of the Winter Soldier and the
events of Captain America Civil War
because after Civil War she's a wanted
fugitive all of the action involving
taskmaster was awesome it's a little
obvious he's Black Widows X but it's
pulled off well enough the real twist is
that Rachel wises character is bad
so Molina / Iron Maiden is bad which is
something that most of us have expected
we even saw her iron maiden mask in the
full Black Widow trailer so iron maiden
/ Molina is the true villain of the
movie and taskmaster and Elena are
working together for Thunderbolt Ross
more on that and just
he goes on to say that Red Guardian dyes
which is what the other leak has said as
well there's some awesome CGI helicopter
scenes which we've seen in the trailers
as well and the hand-to-hand combat
scenes are all really awesome
he says the movie is also really funny
and there's a lot of good jokes in it
and they say that Hawkeye Robert Downey
jr. Nick Fury and Walton Goggins have
cameos now Walter Goggins placed on a
birch and ant-man and the wasp and we
know that he was working for some
mysterious benefactor and based off of
the post-credits scene that I'm about to
tell you we know who it is
so reportedly there are two post-credit
scenes one is Florence pew who of course
plays Jelena Bulova and taskmaster
giving Thunderbolt Ross the flash drive
this is the flash drive that apparently
has the ability to remove anyone's name
from all databases they give him the
flash drive and he tells them that they
are just getting started
the second one is one that we've heard
before is Hawkeye with his children at
Nats grave he's all tatted up like he
was an Avengers end game because of
course it takes place in the present
time because Natasha is dead she really
did die in Avengers end game so those
are the Black Widow post-credit scene
leaks but let's talk about that first
post-credit scene Jelena Bulova and
taskmaster working for Thunder bull Ross
the entire time this is because he is
setting up the Thunderbolts now we've
already gotten reports that the
Thunderbolts were going to be set up
very early on in Marvel's phase 4 as it
turns out they're going to be set up in
the first film of phase 4 which doesn't
come as that big of a shock because
again we see Thunderbolt Ross in the
trailers for the Black Widow movie we
knew that he served some major purpose
of the film more than just tracking
Black Widow down Black Widow isn't the
only person to not abide by the sokovia
accords there were plenty of others and
in the trailers Thunderbolt Ross has a
ton of troops with him and that's not
just to capture Black Widow but now we
know about the flash drive so the fact
that he has a lot more reinforcements
makes a lot of sense
however the flash drive is most likely
not his primary goal he has Yelena and
taskmaster to go and get the flash drive
from Black Widow that is their purpose
he is their first recruits but
Thunderbolt Ross himself is most likely
trying to get a hold of the Super
Soldier Serum that is used on the black
widows the Thunderbolts are clearly
being set up which means we have to have
Red Hulk and how does Thunderbolt Ross
become Red Hulk well it's the serum that
we've seen in the Black Widow trailers
now the vials that hold the serum the
red serum because again it's Red Hulk
are shown a lot in the trailers although
they are never mentioned but we found
out that this is in fact a form of Super
Soldier Serum and the Black Widow
program is using this on the black
widows to control their minds this is
what Thunderbolt Ross wants this is what
he himself is going after in the Black
Widow movie and recently we have learned
that he does in fact get his hands on
this serum and we're going to see it
arise again in the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier Thunderbolt Ross uses this serum
to control the new Captain America u.s.
agent John Walker we find out that Sam
was actually pardoned for everything
that has happened due to his role in
Avengers endgame and he goes on to be
given the opportunity to become the new
Captain America
however the stipulation is that he has
to take the Super Soldier Serum just
like Steve Rogers he ultimately decides
not to and John Walker takes the serum
and now is being mind-controlled by
Thunderbolt Ross
and this is all a part of his plan and
due to the workings of his Thunderbolts
now this isn't something that thunder
borrows has only recently began to work
on if we look back to the Incredible
Hulk this is what he's been planning for
years and years all the way back in 2008
however it was revealed that Thunderbolt
Ross was snapped he was a part of the
half that got snapped away during the
decimation
now of course he came back and we saw
him at the end of Avengers endgame at
Tony Stark's funeral but his whole deal
is that he wants a group of people that
he can control to protect the world that
was the whole thing with the sokovia
accords he had no control over the
Avengers and what they did and he wanted
full control over them he wanted to
control their missions and everything
that they did well since he got snapped
and came back he's most likely increased
his efforts to put together the
Thunderbolt team and that's very
apparent in this leaked post-credit
scene for Black Widow now the
Thunderbolts are also probably going to
be introduced much like The Avengers
were one at a time or a few at a time in
Black Widow we're going to see Elaina
and taskmaster in Falcon and the Winter
Soldier we're most likely going to see
Zemo and there have been talks by the
great leaker Roger Wardell that Justin
hammers going to return and ghost is
going to be returning as
well and not to mention if this leak is
true they said that Sonny Burch is in
the film and that most likely means that
Thunderbolt Ross is the mysterious
benefactor from ant-man and the wasp and
if we think about it it makes perfect
sense so expect a pretty cool
Thunderbolt steam coming to the future
of the MCU most likely coming full force
and the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
and then of course the second
post-credit scene is of Hawkeye with his
family at Natasha's grave this is
basically just paying her respect we
didn't get a funeral for Natasha in
Avengers end game gist Tony Stark and
that made fans pretty mad after all
everybody loves Natasha and it didn't
really make sense that we didn't see a
funeral for her especially after she
sacrificed herself but a perfect tribute
to her would be Hawkeye and his family
who of course all loved her very deeply
the kids even called her aunt NAT so the
closest people to her at her grave pain
respect to her in the post-credits scene
kind of making up for the lack of a
funeral and Avengers end game so those
are the leaks that we have for the plot
and the post-credits scenes for the
Black Widow movie what do you think
about this what do you think about the
plot leaked to post-credit scene and
what do you think about the Thunder
bullets coming to the MCU in the future
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
this video and subscribe when
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on all things relating to the MCU
and I'm picking a winner for my giveaway
at five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers follow me on Twitter for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof